his opponent so well so he'll be able to
start targeting the weaknesses and uh
wait well actually i said
but it's not it's the english that's
right the most played opening on the
tour yeah it's quite funny how they've
all been surprised by that fact but they
all play it they all play it yeah it's a
definite trend and uh maybe it's in
honor of carl here in the studio joining
us the english opening and uh okay how
will ding react uh sorry where you react
he might be trying to transpose into the
queen's gambit declined or at least a
variant of the queen's camera declined
instead we see white fiance's bishop
onto the long diagonal and very very
solid setup from wei yi this was one
i've had myself just countless times
white doesn't take any risk at all in
the opening and now white is pretty
flexible which pawn to push in the
center of the board it could transp
transpose to the catalan opening one of
ding's favorites but maybe where you
will expect that so a bit of mind games
and it does transpose to the catalan
opening a branch of the queen's gambit
declined aha
and wei yi he has 10 points he isn't so
lead in the tournament who won three
games yesterday ding also had a very
good start to the tournament
on eight points is these uh two players
that you are very familiar with carl
um certainly i follow them online like i
do most of the elite players but it's
quite interesting to see the uh the
change in chess style from from my day
if you like all the c4s you know e4 used
to be the move to play to try to win and
now it's d4 or knight f3 or something
else and uh very hard to break these
positions down the the fiance bishop
there on the g2 square it's very
difficult to uh
to break in so maybe it's a longer game
here aha
definitely um there's only been one
trade of pawns and with this last bishop
retreat which is very mysterious
actually from ding moving this dart
square bishop twice
he's saying no exchanges he thinks that
white has a small space advantage
because white's pawn in the center of
the board covers a lot of squares black
may be less influence on those central
squares and he's just saying exactly
what carl's
carl's indicating that just keeping
peace on the board going for a long
grind
so we could be here for a while as ding
tries to eke out a tiny advantage
normally white is pretty safe here but
black is rock solid and i'm just
checking out my database and the two
have actually played each other with the
exact same color exact same position
just last month in april in this match
that you referenced and that particular
game ended in a draw but here we go
where you by moving the queen has
actually deviated from the original game
and this is his improvement i love it
when the players you know follow their
lines and then they play something
different and you're like oh now we get
to see your preparation mind games maybe
were you just saying okay i've studied
this all before it's not new to me
and okay ding took a few seconds to
compose himself and brings out his
knight very logical white would love to
throw more pawns forward in the center
of the ward if possible simon what are
your thoughts on this type of position
any experience here
not personally i mean i've looked at a
lot of games like this and sometimes i
get in these kind of structures um very
solid uh i think as carl said um it it's
the new trend to try and win uh now
playing these longer types of games e4
unfortunately in move one at elite level
has kind of been worked out so well
especially with the berlin coming around
since 2000 that is is considered quite
draw-ish i mean you know the one thing i
found quite fascinating about the
players from china though is you know
they've they've shot up in the last sort
of 20 years or so from nowhere and um
you know it's it's said that their team
spirit is incredible so they work
everything together they share secrets
they they have this incredible uh sort
of mutual learning together which maybe
other other countries could certainly uh
benefit from you know i i know in
england it's all kind of like everyone
for themselves unfortunately a little
bit you know it it shouldn't be but
that's that's maybe why they've got so
many great players because they have
that super strong women's team as well
right yeah the strongest women's team in
the world must be yeah and i i've been
asking them about this because you know
because we hear about those kind of
rumors you know this chess house where
all the top players are studying yeah
and so they the women's team actually
revealed to me
that they themselves actually didn't
conform to that whole stereotype that
made me the men's team yes but for the
women's team they were very much uh
independent they were based on regions
so some of them were shanghai and those
in shanghai worked together and were
very good friends but the others in
different parts of the country also
worked with their set of trainers
so i was like because i was grilling
them on everything yeah tell me more
tell me why i just want to know
absolutely everything but uh yeah yeah i
imagine it's like the oh spoiler alert
but the final episode of the queen's
gambit where you know they get together
and they kind of exactly pull their
resources and uh kind of support each
other and i'm i've got no doubt if ding
does indeed play in the candidates that
wei is going to be helping him maybe
with some opening knowledge maybe with
some inside kind of information about
some kind of specifics on the opponents
interesting so yeah that's one thing
that as simon says we definitely don't
do in england and i think a lot of
countries didn't do until recently but
that's another reason that india for
example have suddenly shot up in the
last 10 years because it's teamwork and
uh they don't treat each other as rivals
they just think okay the end goal is
becoming the best in the world so why
not kind of use each other to reach that
and it must be a lot of fun as well
working together in a team because it
can be we talked about it chess can be a
lonely sport
yeah definitely it's so much more fun to
kind of be part of the group yeah and
just to kind of share your ideas use
them as a springboard just to get
creative
and i also heard another rumor i don't
know how
true this is but as i'll put it out
there it says basically that once you
reach reach a certain age
you're kind of asked to retire
and uh take on
teaching responsibilities in china yeah
what's the age i'm interested now
21 20
how does how old is thing i don't know
how old he is but clearly he's where he
is 22 where he is 22 and he was born in
1992 so okay so he's maybe 29 uh always
ancient then
it's an interesting philosophy it might
be it's a great idea it might be a
fantastic idea to have the twenty nine
years
yeah yeah might have you know top
players you know just once they reach
their peak you know say well great
inspire the minds i remember chris
alexander grouschuk sasha was telling me
when i was doing commentary with him he
was saying uh well you know there's this
saying that you know the best players
play and then those who are not the best
players or lost it a little bit they
teach and then everyone else
so the commentators are at the bottom
i'm afraid guys
but now you can make chessable courses
as well yes
i don't believe that i have to say i
just want to put it out there
how about how about team spirit and
prisons carl is it every man or woman
for
um him or herself or do they work
together as well it's very very
interesting i mean prison as anyone can
imagine is a pretty
lonely place at times and there are
different groups of people that stick
together or don't
when you get them in a room playing
chess the officers often say to me i've
never seen this before these people
would never mix normally it's it's a
quiet pastime and i've been to some
prisons where i've given a symbol and
they've come to me with a file of my
games that they've had the officers
download and say we've done some work on
you we know you play the french defense
and so we're playing that today of
course i then point out that they made
their first mistake and told and i've
said well now i won't play the french
today so all of that work has gone down
but then they work together and so you
can imagine it's
the mail is particularly very
testosterone filled there's lots of
comments you can hear down the end you
know i'm i've got him i've got his queen
i'm going to hammer him he's going down
and all that and it's just trash talk
and
they do they do work together and if one
of them gets the result they they share
the joy in that and so
it's good it's really good when they do
do that as well because they they've
achieved something yeah and it's just
interesting to note that if you the
first time somebody beat me i gave them
credit and they didn't want to take it
because they'd not been given credit
really in their life before and i
demonstrated by playing the moves that
they did deserve to beat me they did
play fairly and they did deserve their
book prize and you know that's that's
part of the joy of it
wow oh so many of the cool stories we're
going to hear from you today carl and
these two teammates in china but in this
game oh and we have a smile from ding i
wonder what that is about
but in this game there are opponents and
we did have a few moves this is still
looking like that long game i think yes
it's going to be a long game but it is a
critical moment and maybe that's why
ding is smiling he knows he's been
caught out in wei yi's homework in his
opening preparation just look at the
clock times ding now he spent around
five minutes wei yi has one minute more
than he started the game with and
black's last move is not an obvious one
either we just have to jump in to show
what's happened over the last few turns
um we were discussing it around here
saying it's going to be a long game
we're not sure exactly which pieces are
going to get traded off which pawns are
going to push but i think white was
indeed ready to start throwing pawns
forward in the center of the board so
before this happened wei decided okay if
white pushes this pawn forward black is
going to be cramped for space when
you're cramped for space you should
trade things off so he captured this
white knight the knight the bishop was
recaptured and instead of defending this
pawn which it looks uh i mean it looks
like this pawn is up for grabs simply
instead of that we counter attacked
against white pawn in the center of the
board and now for example if the white
bishop takes this pawn black i think uh
his plan is a bit sneaky he wants to
jump in with his knight giving up his
knight attacking this bishop but if the
knight is captured then black sword gets
super active and it's variations like
this that wei yi has probably studied
before with a computer he's probably
realized that okay he can sacrifice
pawns go active with the black rook and
the reason ding i think was smiling is
because
he knew that he couldn't continue
walking into the lion's den and uh he
had to avoid wadi's preparation so
instead of allowing um sorry instead of
capturing this white uh this black pawn
he's decided okay let's just shuffle the
queen forward and now if the white pawn
is captured in the center of the board i
think only then will he consider maybe
taking this pawn or maybe first throwing
his bishop to attack the black rock kick
it back and when it retreats then grab a
pawn lots of moves there but it's all
about which pawn is more valuable in the
current position is it white central
pawn or is it this black pawn that's
eyed up by the light squared bishop and
uh if we wants a longer game then he'll
maybe just push forward block this
bishop out if he wants to really solve
black's problems quickly then maybe
he'll consider taking this pawn but that
is by far the riskier option okay
well the bar is uh quite calm still
slightly over to wei's side
and uh
ding is definitely the the player who
spent the most time in this opening
where he played very fast yeah and uh
big bottle of water isn't it as well
super size always hydrate when you're
playing just yeah definitely what i'd
say it could be that he's a very small
person of course
it's a normal size yeah absolutely
very normal
i kind of want to check dingley ren's
height as well
that's on there you just don't know
we'll see
a half liter bottle
while you're checking guy i'd like to
whilst i'm in a steamed company i'd like
to ask a question
um
do you think the chinese believe
that they could have the next male
world champion do you think that they
actually believe that they could do it
you've got people like ali raza farooza
do you really think they believe they
can do it
yeah i think so
i mean
i think the proof as well was just last
month when ding he was inactive
technically
i mean he was going to miss out on this
place in the candidates and they hadn't
organized any of the board tournaments
in china for almost two years and then
suddenly just for ding just to get him
into the candidates they organized all
these events so they must believe in him
and uh if not him then maybe you'll have
to go down a generation or two um
i'm going to find the next prospect but
i remember one story david it's maybe
not a great story
i don't know if you want to mention it
but it
did weirdly make me laugh in a very bad
way but uh maybe
david
yeah it's uh i won't name the arbiter
involved but um in 2016 england were
playing china in the olympiad and it was
a crucial game we were kind of locked on
points and we were doing quite well at
the time england
um but i'm known for arriving a bit late
i think that's one of the first times in
my life i've arrived the first uh to a
game so um the england team the chinese
team no one had arrived i sat down on
the england side of the board and the
arbiter was just looking at me so i
wrote down my name my stuff and he came
up to me and said sorry you're sitting
on the wrong side
and i was like no uh i'm playing for
england he's like no no you're sitting
on the wrong side china
that's pretty bad yeah this is pretty
bad only when i showed him my badge only
when i got my team captain to come and
tell him proof then he finally believed
me but uh yeah i was kind of saved by
ding arriving and shaking my hand and
sitting down that he realized how did
you get on against uh it was a draw okay
uh because i wasn't playing i was
actually watching it with one of uh
our participants gawain jones and uh
england beat chyna in that match i
remember that's incredible
jane and i literally hugged each other
he jumped for joy and we're like oh my
goodness me i think maybe david was in
the room as well
maybe i have a feeling yeah maybe he
finished he finished quite early yeah i
had i mean it was quite a quick draw i
actually had an advantage with black
very early on after the opening
from something not too dissimilar to
this but okay as in a team event as
black and draw is great i was outraged
by 200 points against ding so i thought
okay let's take the draw and we won the
match
wow incredible yeah super strong chinese
team yeah that was a
kind of a rollercoaster day for me
and yeah i did apologize afterwards okay
good um so okay a couple of moves and
actually one of the options we did
mention there has been a trade of pawns
so white central pawn has disappeared
and black's pawn on the b file has
disappeared
white does have the bishop pair and
things are starting to open up so if ye
isn't accurate here then just white
having the two bishops could be a bit of
a factor but black is very active black
has a kind of cluster of pieces um in
the center of the board on the dark
squares and
yeah still in the balance
david i'm putting in like a
simple-minded horse here i know but from
the perspective of my grade of players
if i'm coaching juniors for example i
might look at that position and say just
for a moment
in your head
take away all of the pieces and leave
the pawns and just look at the pawn
structure and so black has got those two
separated pawns over on the queen side
and black and white has got pawns
together if you like his friends with
two on the left and the four on the
right and if it got down to an end game
where all the pieces were off whilst
there's no guarantees i would like to
think that i would probably prefer to
play white
because the the
pawn on c7 down there is a target and in
fact on e5
so white
so black must be aware of this and must
be wanting to make something happen
before they got to that stage definitely
exactly and that's why we talk about
kind of long-term positional strategic
play and that's exactly what carl's
talking about there um the pawns are a
long-term target also white has these
two great bishops which will kind of
control a lot of squares long term and
that's why black has to play dynamically
has to be kind of very
energetic with the play you can't just
trade everything off you can't for
example trade off pieces for no reason
you have to maybe get all your pieces to
active squares for now these three
pieces create a nice kind of impression
uh controlling a lot of squares maybe
hinting at attacking some stuff later on
but uh yeah it's very much black has to
play for the short term um long term
white is the one with all the chances
and he has now finally started thinking
wait what could be a plan for him here
and he's just jumped in a bit of a
flashy move here he's jumped in with the
black knight it's a double attack
hitting the rook in the corner and
hitting the bishop it looks like the
knight is up for grabs but if white
takes it then the bishop drops the white
queen is lured away and no protection of
the bishop so actually here i talked
about the bishop pair now it's opposite
colour bishops so long term
maybe black is feeling a bit safer it's
going to be very hard to attack these
two pawns while black kind of keeps his
dark squad bishop on the board so looks
like a very solid decision by weiyi he
just spent a bit of time calculating
this move but it does indeed work and we
will see some exchanges but there's
exchanges that kind of uh favor black
here he's going to get rid of this key
dart squad bishop for white okay
it's a great move by way you there and
one of the kind of like calling cards of
the chinese players is they're very very
good at calculation and tactics and
spotting these little opportunities and
it's
a problem piece has been removed from
the board and now i think
the pawn structure doesn't matter so
much because they're all going to be on
dark squares and
like has a dark square bishop yeah i
think while knights remain on the board
maybe the black pawn structure is still
not so great you can imagine the white
knight jumping around and maybe
attacking some pawns later on but if
black can exchange knights off the board
now i think that would lock down a draw
yeah i think the pieces are coming off
the board yeah i suppose black's got
this nice control over the queen side as
well i mean there are some weaknesses in
in white's position if you look at
black's bishop that bishop is in a
lovely square and you can't kick that
bishop away so there are some positives
about having these these pawns on the
queen scythe black and
well opposite kind of bishops it does
often indicate it will be a draw um so
more exchanges i expect it's heading
that way but you know probably yeah
and uh sometimes this is all down to the
opening because uh some openings are
just really tough not to crack
as white you don't get too much as black
maybe your struggle against certain
pressures and i'm just mentioning this
because you know i don't think ding has
got that much is entirely happy with how
he's done he's opened with the white
pieces and of course our quiz of the day
that's my link is uh of course what
opening move annoys you the most yes and
uh everyone is coming up with answers
and maruko
actually says that the most annoying
thing is when you play
e4 e5 which is pawn to king four four
moves two five square uh two squares
forward and then white plays the bomb
cloud
king goes to the e2 and he goes the
worst thing is that if you lose against
this
you feel like the worst player in the
world i feel you i feel you totally
remember that from the last season in
the tour hikaru and magna is playing
that against yeah at least they drew
though yeah i mean i think magnus has
played the bomb cloud in all seriousness
and one yeah and you feel like oh
goodness me
yeah it's worth remembering that the
difference is
they know what they're doing
that's real
yeah
oh yeah anyone not to recommend not to
try at home
definitely but also i mean just thinking
back to
last month's tour event where magnus
opened with that one f3 yeah which is
kind of like a joke opening yeah
and it must be annoying to face yeah and
he played against duda and and judo was
just like totally the rest of the day
yeah it just yeah it didn't work his way
and then he kind of quickly lost game
three and that was i mean of course he
managed to bounce back and win the
tournament but yeah
it was a good psychological ploy so how
about you guys worst move that you face
in games
i'd probably say similar actually i mean
um if if you're playing someone and they
play something completely ridiculous
against she was like oh come on you know
it's like you know you're kind of
disrespectful
a little bit i think yeah i mean i was
getting a quick game of chess in earlier
and i was playing some french guy and
you know we got to rook and king versus
rook and king
similar and it's which is a dead dead
draw and the guy just played on and i'm
just like oh come on you must have
better things to do with your life
bits are annoyed about it at all
yeah and we both have 30 seconds left
and i just like i can't be bothered you
know so just
some of these little things can be a
little bit disrespectful yeah you know
they get you know make you a bit angry
so uh and i think if someone did that
against me it'd be like okay yeah very
funny you're hilarious so funny yeah it
hasn't been seen before
but you're not really thinking and if
you lose it's even worse so um yeah so i
think the guy had a good point it was
twitter post very good point very good
point yeah
yeah i think for me it's when my
opponent when i'm playing black when i'm
playing someone maybe slightly lower
rated than me when they just try and
draw and it's so hard sometimes to
create winning chances with the black
pieces
in kind of must-win situations
because i just i mean you guys know me i
like to play long games where it's uh
kind of try and squeeze out any
potential winning chances but
it's it's tricky yeah if the opponent is
dead set on just trading everything off
it can be hard to keep the game alive
yeah the westerners went online when
they they push all their pawns onto
one's one row and they do that you know
they keep nice and solid and like come
on come on let's see what you're gonna
do and i hate that because they're just
playing to win on time that's it oh
annoying how about you carl
well there is an opening called the grub
never heard about it played in the old
days i'm here to talk about the old days
obviously and it was playing the old
days and it's basically
equivalent to a slap in the face with a
wet haddock g4 this move pawn to g4
which flies in the face of everything
you ever learned about chess and says
i don't care about you i'm just going to
play my game and i'll beat you and
somebody played it against me not too
long ago
fair enough they were an international
master and they did win but i was still
really annoyed you may be and i am but
you play g4 against me oh and we're
about to see a draw by repetition
yeah everything's come off the board
opposite color bishops nothing to do and
it is a draw all right